my name is Aldo mousse I am the CTO
chief law and I'm going to talk about
live kind of numerics where knowledge
meat computation and we are working on
solving integral differential equations
with high precision and full control of
the accuracy today I'm going to do talk
about the work that we are doing a
chippy flow that is we are developing
solvers for integral differential
equations ranging from just calculating
definite integrals to CFT work and also
in finance or quantum mechanics any type
of differential equations we named as
our talk as a new kind of numerics
because we believe that it is time for
changing how we are doing numerix and
i'm going to start with a classical
mathematical starting if you are in an
elementary presentation of Mathematica
this is what you will generally see PI -
mm is years or five thousand digits and
in here I have to question why at the
beginning Mathematica choose to do this
like why giving PI to the 2030s why high
precision calculations and what we can
do with this that being said let's go
and see what we can do with this so I
have a model in here which requires a
differentiation between 10 to the minus
almost 200 and 0 and this is a snow
wheel fluid modeling this is a academic
work done with turkey in Boston
University and there we are modeling a
snow will fluid which is a fluid between
your joints I'm not going to go into
detail of the model this is your
momentum balance this is your
concentration and you have a viscosity
parameter which depends on the r-value
and the source source term this is
Highline linear nonlinear system and
depending on the R value you are getting
some flow profiles and when R equal to
some like Lisa 2.2 you're getting a flow
profile like this in here the slope
looks like zero but it is actually not
it has to be really close to zero but it
cannot be zero then you almost lose
whole physical configuration of the
problem it is almost like the strain
that you are going to apply to your knee
will break your leg kind of problem so
the slope has to come to 0 to get a
physical solution but cannot be 0 so in
this problem you really need to take
advantage of what Mathematica is
offering that high precision calculation
but with that with that being said how
we are doing this so we are looking into
a steady solution in here and defining a
parameter from the steady solution when
the de DT is equal to 0 this term is
constant and we are defining a K
parameter which has to be a constant
parameter because it is equal to du the
derivative of it is equal to 0 and we
define a special convergence criteria
it's not really that important for this
purpose like for this talk but the K has
to be constant so if it our method the
cherry flow method we are obtaining K
constant for throughout the domain and
you see how many number of digits in
here and when you're using classical
finite volume approach this is what you
get for K that's supposed to be constant
throughout the domain and like in every
numerical method you have number of
points that you're evaluating your
discretizing your domain and you are
looking for convergence which is defined
in here with us
like the converges exponential reaching
to 10 to the minus 16 in this point like
an 200 point by around 100 points this
is log scale and same for same R this is
the finite volume solver and if just you
extrapolate that slope the slope of this
curve you'll reach somewhere here which
will be expected to be 10 to the power 8
points that you will need to obtain such
a result if it is possible without
roundoff error propagation or divergence
this I keep doing it I'm saving it the
rest will be larger this is just the
equation sine was never able to do that
so
from here okay so when you have such a
powerful numerical method what we can do
with this and this is an example from
mathematical documentation where they
are trying we are trying to integrate
this function this is a highly
oscillatory function and I'm we were
doing this numerically we told me that
we sound something peculiar and we want
to investigate little further and for
that we just dropped this X in this
integral in this function just for
simplicity and all so that we can
represent that sine square X as an
exponential exactly just to show you
that this sine X square and sine X
square plus X is almost identical when
you are reaching at the end of the
domain so they are really really close
functions and as I said we choose this
way of doing this problem because we
want to represent this function in two
different ways and I'm just going to
show you that that two functions are
really identical I'm not going to run
this one but what I'm doing in here I'm
getting an F 1 F 2 I am just
symbolically subtracting them and then
numeric to doing the same thing I'm
getting symbolic difference equal to 0
and in numerical difference whatever
number of digits that I asked so so
these two functions are numerical and
symbolic identical that means that when
I'm integrating these two functions I
have to obtain a same integral result so
I'm going to integrate these functions
symbolically that's important part then
I'm going to evaluate them and I'm going
to just look at the difference with
different number of digits and what turn
out to be the sine function gave as
friend l and this exponential function
gave an error function and I'm just
first started with forty number of
digits I get ten to the minus nine forty
five I get ten to the minus nine as you
go to the minus sign so I'm not getting
zero in here so there's something going
on so what I did we did is we
numerically integrate using our method
first of all sine X Square and
symbolically integrate that and the
difference between symbolic and our
numerical calculation is 10 to the minus
nine as I keep increasing my accuracy
parameter that
what we call PV and it is ten to the
minus nine so there is something going
on so I went to the second function then
I even laid this function symbolically
and keep iterating this guy numerically
and I did get the result that I'm
looking for like 10 to the minus 50 10
to the minus 500 so that means that what
was happening in here is Mathematica was
failing to even a different L correctly
in that two region with that being said
so when you have such a powerful method
and when you are seeing such
inconsistencies from time to time the
user has a question how can you be sure
that these articles is provided in
essence we believe that we can be a
numerical reference even emulating
symbolic functions with our powerful
method and we can do also other stuff
with this of course after seeing that we
had to do some our own friend LS when L
see an error function calculation I'm
just going to show you these are really
fast functions these are let's say 30
digits I just want to obtain them and
you get the total digits of Rennell
error function and the next stuff that
I'm going to show you our little solvers
let's say for say that checks if the
given function and the function is C
infinite this is important when you are
dealing with physical problems such as
heat diffusion on your putting diffusion
coefficient which is not C infinite that
means it is not something physical that
you are trying to solve the other one is
the factorization and we are looking
into an MD function if it arises as a
product or some this helps you increase
the efficiency of your competition
instead of let's say working 3d array or
metrics you can work three 1d arrays if
it is possible to check this
automatically so let me run these ones
and also as you see for the first one
I'm giving a range for Z and for teeth
to check if it is C infinite and I'm
going to check this on almost similar
functions if there are products or some
of the given ones so yes it is the given
function in here is C infinite for the
was given in here and the function in
here that I represented is not a product
of T or X but it is product of Z that
means that you can relate this part of
the function and you can relate this
part of the function and multiply that
means instead of working with 3d matrix
you can work 1 1 1 D and 1 2 D this will
increase a lot the efficiency of your
computation a similar thing for the
summation you see it is this time it is
T that you can even it separately this
part you have to relate together so
again 1 1 D 1 to D that being said let's
look at the one integral where we find
this final issue with us with and I'm
just showing the method that is shown in
the mathematical documentation and I'm
hunting hunting for a high-precision
result 400 and I'm using the right
symbolic definition to look at the exact
result and the x is 160 seconds 485 10
to the minus 85 for us the time is for
42 seconds for almost 200 ten to the
minus 200 and I'm going to run a
calculation for that just to show you
let me just clean my kernel let me load
my package and I'm going to integrate
this function from 0 to 1 is the highly
oscillatory function and what I deal
only is I'm giving the function I'm
doing the limits of the integration and
how many number of digits I want to
result to be given and let me run this
and as ATM was showing I'm also able to
show how many number of digits are
converted throughout the calculation so
this is kinda nice giving the user hey
it is working and also you see how many
number of digits is converging what time
and it takes 11 seconds and you get a
convert result and if you want higher
accuracy you can just input a larger
number in here you can put on atomic
later on that it will do it you don't
need to change any method or anything it
will just converge and things are of
course more complicated when you come to
the ending integrals this is again an
example for mathematic
documentation this is the function that
we are going trying to integrate and
what is given in here is I just copy
paste from the documentation adapting
Montecarlo it by section deterring said
that this is a satisfactory estimation
and I'm just going to run the same thing
in here just to show what the result is
this is going to be really quick it is
like point three seconds but the
convergence is ten to the minus three
let's say what about I am working with
Mathematica I want high precision okay
so what about high precision so I do it
the same thing with adapting Mentos
color but this time I am putting working
precision 400 so I'm shooting for
something like 50 digits of accuracy and
I'm obtaining 22 minus 6 for 14 seconds
and I've been told that this is not the
best way of doing it
so I just did use another method which
is obtaining much better accuracy
actually 10 to the minus almost hundred
with 16 seconds what about us what we
can do I am going to do something even
harder than what I showed there because
that's really simple I'm going to do the
3d version of this function so this is
the 2d this is the 2d function this is
the exact result this is the 3d version
of it I'm just going to do the 3d
version of it let's first start with 20
digits of acres I'm just have n the
number of digits 20 and let me run it
you have 20 digits of accuracy in 0.6
seconds you asked for 200 degrees of
accuracy you have it in 1.3 seconds you
have told 23 districts accuracy and this
is not limited to you can do to whatever
you want like you can just keep
increasing and in this n series that we
like to call we have this C infinite and
as you saw this factorization we have a
solo for in condition linear system
eigenspace linear integral differential
equation solvers we have an OD which is
the order of OD is unlimited where the
coefficients for the right now is the
constant coefficient but the order can
be hundred
who would use hundred maybe the
electrical circuits do need something
like that but we are capable of doing it
with that being said I'm talking about
accuracy but accused is a really
slippery word I mean it's hard to
describe what do you mean by acoustic so
I'm just going to give some facts about
accuracy so whatever you do as a digital
representation or number of accurate
digits it is always limited no matter
what it is not symbolic so it is going
to be always limited and there will
always a roundoff error propagation and
amplification it can be coming from your
discretization method and the resulting
method will always lead to keep the
largest error committed in the
calculation so and also it is really
really not easy to predict where this
error is coming from so the best is to
use everything best possible starting
from your numerical calculation that is
our philosophy that the result can
confirm that we have the full contours
control of the accuracy that's important
I'm not always talking about higher
crease I'm talking about giving the
control of accuracy easily to the user
so we believe that we are able to do
that with Mathematica and in using our
method of doing numerical calculation
how we are doing this is from the name
it is little bit happen to some people I
assume it is we are using kind of
approximation from chebyshev's work and
what we like to say is we are bringing
19th century math to do 21st century new
works and we believe that it was first
real decomposition then it came the term
of approximation now it is our time to
do things and why now why not like 10
years ago when Mathematica started this
is really small but what is you seen
here number of transistors on a CPU
versus year so when the numerical
calculation started with finite methods
it was in here that those methods are
designed for so the computation power
was really limited we require the
computation power this is my Mathematica
started and it is still not there yet
but currently we are in here we have 20
billion transistors in one CPU and this
is continuously going so why
to use a numerical method designed for
this kind of computers of it there's a
time for change in numerix so what else
we are doing we are able to do a little
higher diffusion problems they said
coming to the computational fluid
dynamics and we like these kind of
functions that multi scale because they
are not really easy to solve and here
throughout my talk I'm always having a
analytical solution just to compare as
right now I'm going to have to we have U
of X in here and then I know so I can
get the f of X and I know the boundary
condition I'm just going to put a do the
condition in here a normal condition in
here that means that u equal to
something give you DX equal to zero so
it and we are going to do first this
steady steady version of it and again
it's only going to be one parameter to
solve the problem PV and again I'm going
to give the full control to the user
cursor and I'm just going to compare the
final result to just to check it and we
have also an internal error estimation
which I'm not going to plot in here but
I can answer the questions later on so
for 1.2 seconds let's say you get 10 to
the minus 6 let's say I want 10 to the
minus 50 and let me run that it is going
to be like 3 seconds or so okay 4
seconds you get 10 to the minus 50 we
can do similar thing with unsteady ok so
let me let me first compare the US with
a finite simple finite volume solution
this is this one was the one that I
first show this is the slope of finite
volume this is the slope for us this is
the finite volume solution that the
second-order finite volume solution this
is us as you see this is lazier than
this guy because we had that insulation
boundary condition on the right hand
side the normal condition that makes it
lazy to converge and I try to do this
using nd so and I use the explicit [ __ ]
Kutub I don't know if this is the best
way of doing it but it took like six
minutes to obtain 10 to the minus 20
results
for us 10 to the minus 50 was four
seconds we can do this with an unsteady
version and it all touch JB flow of
touch that doing this calculation I'm
not going to ask anything about time
step or a final time the result that I'm
going to give you is going to be
continuous in time for you okay
and let me just load my packages again
I'm choosing a function setup that I
know the result giving these two
boundary conditions it's Neumann binding
conditions both sides and I'm going to
solve this problem
okay the calculation is finished now I'm
going to ask you where you want to see
the time let's say from 2 to 11 or they
say 22 31 you have the whole spectrum of
the time without any limitation of time
step and what about the accuracy in here
let me just compare with the exact
result this is 10 to the minus 40
accuracy that we have in this P series
toolboxes we have this diffusion with
different cutting different coordinate
system instead it's again different
coordinate system different cavity 2d
and 3d 2d different carroty and to the
thermal coupler cavity right now and
moving on to CFD computational fluid
dynamics in the commercial methods which
I say like finite methods at the end the
result that you're obtaining is a
polynomial or descriptive that is
questionable for us it's for sure a
continuous polynomial approximation and
this is really important because what
you see in here one polynomial solution
so meaning that whatever a crucian here
is the recursion here so it's a global
approach to the diffusion problem which
diffusion problem is global problem and
the important thing that you need to see
in here is the wall speed increases
you're stuck there's a layer in here
that is really small and this is really
hard to obtain it any finite methods
because what they are not able to obtain
a large scale and small scale at the
same time what they would like to do is
put more points in here as you put more
points
these are not uniform anymore and you
just degrade your order of accuracy
which is all which was already law and
on top of that you cannot just be
accurate in here I think that okay
nothing is happening in here the
momentum transfer in here causes this
flow to be stuck in here so you need to
be accurate everywhere with this we can
do a complex system we are waiting on a
patent in this so we have a multi
material medium that I'm doing a heat
conduction in here I am applying a
temperature difference in here and
insulation and this is a one domain
problem for us we are not really
describing any boundaries for this disk
meaning that the solution is not jumping
like if we don't put anything like T
equal to T DT DX equal to DT DX so there
is no degrading of your solution
solution is C infinite whatever order of
your accuracy is your solution is
everywhere is the same and we can do
complex stuff like this non orthogonal
geometries in heat conduction and I'm
just going to exit from the presentation
because for some reason in the
presentation I am NOT able to show up
videos I'm just going to show you two
videos to you that this we can do the
similar thing with the unsteady you have
an analyst in here highly conductive the
middle part is less conductive so we can
do this thing
unsteady and for flow problem I'm going
to show you a drink MIT with a non non
orthogonal geometry in here the
important thing is happening that
actually at the corner this is really
really hard to obtain with any finite
method it's probably almost impossible
to obtain such a nice result that being
said we can also do flow problems
flow problems with obstacles around it
and this is again the same method that
we showed in heat conduction and meaning
that this solution is continuous so the
wall in here is part of the solution
actually meaning that you are obtaining
a C infinite solution completely
differentiable and this will give you
let's say an advantage was the ordering
post-processing in CFD which is really
important when you are calculating
stresses on the walls and things like
that to have a continuous solution is
extremely important and we are able to
do this stuff in Mathematica which
generally in many of these talks I never
see Mathematica used in this manner but
Mathematica is a really clever tool and
if it is used cleverly it can make a lot
of things and for our safety solvers
again we are only talking about one
parameter to control their accuracy and
you have all the accuracy that you want
you can be less acute or extremely the
user is choosing this that's the
important part without changing any
method without any special things and we
are guaranteeing exponential convergence
it is guaranteed and we respect the
physics of the problem meaning that if
you have an experiment and if you give
me the exact boundary conditions from
your experiment you will see what you
see in your experiment in your computer
exactly so that is really important
because we are not really using any ad
hoc models such as turbulence or we are
not using any stabilizers to keep the
solution stable so it is respecting the
physics of the problem with that being
said we are working on right now an OD
which this coefficient is non constant
3d versions of the solvers that I showed
you and also we can also do many other
things like in mathematical finance
quantum mechanics physics biology if you
ever if you have an integral
differential equation it is our domain
that we can solve it highly accurately
and with that I just would like to thank
you and I'm happy to answer your
questions
you